at the very beginning we had the private
gear right so there are only two options
one of the most familiar options is
basically I will store the private key
on my computer or I will have a legend I
know right and that will start the
entire private key right that had a
bunch of issues you know one issue is
that if you start on your computer and
your computer is hacked and you have a
malware it will steal your private key
and the the hackers will run away with
all your money then in 2012 or so we
came up with multisig which was a
specific protocol for for Bitcoin that
allowed us to kind of have multiple keys
that can control an address right and
that actually solved the issue of a
single point of failure
[Music]
what's going on guys bang bang got
Michael here with me uh I thought a
great place to start is the current
banking crisis and obviously there is
this kind of Fiat World there is a
Bitcoin in crypto world but in the Fiat
world most people don't think about
crisis where they store their deposits
they don't think about counterparty risk
they don't think about you know what is
the bank doing with my money once I give
it to them but now all of that is kind
of risen up to you know the surface and
now that is a topic of conversation how
do you evaluate what's happening with
all of those Banks and some of the
problems they're running into
yeah so I mean I think we are definitely
in a very Uncharted Territory with uh
with you know some of those Banks and
you know honestly I'm not an expert in
the uh kind of In traditional Finance
but I think you know even ourselves we
have this uh uh exposure to svb that
luckily we managed as a as a company we
moved actually the assets from svb the
beginning of February so we sort of like
you know dodged that the entire uh
Fiasco but when you think about what
actually happened over there and how it
plays Into The Narrative of crypto
the first thing is really what is the
counterpart risk and what is the
transparency that you have in the
traditional Financial system and I think
that what you said is sort of on point
that when you put your money in the bank
right and you're seeing it in the
checking account I think most of the
people most of the population
thinks that the money is over there
right that's you basically log into your
bank account and if you deposited one
thousand dollars they show you that you
have one thousand dollars and people
actually think that there is one
thousand dollars in in that account they
don't actually know that in order for
the bank to have his business model his
lender and as long as it is both the
checking and saving account right there
they're basically taking this money and
they lending it or they putting it to
work right and then you are essentially
exposed to their investment uh
philosophy or exposed to their
investment risk and then as we've seen
you know with as we and a few of those
other folks that
um you
you know now it basically depends on
their competence you know the first
thing and the second is actually also
depends on some some you know what the
FED what the federal regulators and what
are the central banks are actually doing
with the economy
when we look at that kind of traditional
Financial system it is a custodial
system right you're giving your funds to
that bank they're obviously doing
everything that that has kind of now
been unpacked and explained to the
average consumer is there a world where
in a Fiat system we could have a
non-custodial uh type engagement where
yes you could have physical cash and put
under your mattress but like are there
ways that you could actually interact
with uh some sort of financial service
and have it be done in a non-custodial
way
you know it can exist but it will it
will require us to move into a system
where the cash is represented on a
blockchain right that we will actually
have a natively issued a central bank
digital currency and whether it's a
wholesale or retail and potentially by
virtue of rapping even if it's a
wholesale so for the folks that are not
familiar with the terminology Central
Bank digital currency is effectively a
situation that in which the central
banks instead of issuing um kind of
those you know dollar dollar accounts
that are either in the form of cash or
in the form of uh
um you know digital deposits that they
would that they provide to the different
banks it's it's basically issued on a on
a blockchain uh whether it's public or
permission but it's actually issued
already on the blockchain and this is
the only place in which it is being
represented and the whole sales central
cbdc is a situation that basically only
the banks have access to that rail so
very similar to what is happening right
now in in the traditional Theater
economy that you know you have Bank of
America and JP Morgan and you know all
those Banks they are the only one that
have access to the fed and they are the
only one that will have access to cbdc
and Retail cbdc is actually something
which is more similar to what we're
seeing in in China where
it looks a bit like what we are familiar
with usdc and with the stable coins that
you can actually have the currency in
your wallet right so it basically
propagates to the end consumer and there
is a debate you know in
um it's actually like you know very
philosophical debate on whether Western
Western
countries like the United States and
Europe uh which model is the the right
model because you know you have you are
exposed to privacy and other questions
that uh probably people didn't care that
much when they are interacting in a
country like China with this and then if
it's actually just basically stops at
the bank level
then the banks can use a natively issued
stablecoin like usdc or paxus or and so
on to basically propagate that a
mechanism to the End customer this is
probably saying that the model
and clearly if we are moving into that
kind of system then you can have
non-custodial exposure to Fiat right in
a way that doesn't require you to
basically you know go to the ATM
withdraw the cache and put it under the
mattress right you can effectively have
that cash truly represented on a digital
Ledger on a blockchain in the account
and then if you own the key you own the
key and no one else can basically
manipulate the assets and the fear that
is in your account
as we look at uh this kind of custodial
risk or this counterparty risk obviously
this has been a topic of discussion also
in the crypto world as well we've seen a
number of custodial centralized services
that have uh succumbed to bad trading
potential fraud and a whole host of
other issues how do you look at these
potential superiority of kind of this
new Financial system over the old
Financial system or is it actually
something where they're parallel systems
and the same risks actually exist in
each of them and so a user whether
you're in the traditional Financial
world or this new one needs to
underwrite the risk in either scenario
how do you think about that
so in the traditional World especially
when you talk about real like big money
or you're talking about assets that are
not uh specifically fear that can be
represented in the form of a dollar bill
you don't have an option to go
non-custodial okay you have to be
custodial right whether you are you know
if you want to have no one will I think
you know unless you are you know running
some kind of illicit activity and you're
not going to have millions of dollars
sitting in cash uh in uh in your garage
right so the the custodial option is
probably the only option and
specifically if you now want to interact
with
Securities right so for example you want
to have access to bonds or you want to
have access to to equity then it also
has to be custodial because eventually
the certificate that
this Government Bond Belongs to You sits
in dtcc which is the depart depository
Trust Company it points into the
custodial Bank say JPMorgan Bank of New
York State Street points to and
eventually it points to some brokerage
accounts that belongs to you right so it
has to be that uh custodial relationship
um you're not going to go to the DC and
basically pick uh like a you know a
paper certificate and you know take it
home
when we when we think about crypto in
crypto you sort of see both models right
so when we talk about mostly
the centralized exchanges or the
centralized lenders whether it's uh you
know uh coinbase FTX I'm not putting
them like in the same bucket of course
you know one of them is a very
legitimate and uh well-run business and
the other one we know what happened
right and we're talking about block five
or Celsius and some of those players
they're clearly writing we're riding out
of the custodial
a framework but you also see quite a lot
of activity that is a non-custodial
right so we have the ydx we have a
compound we have Ave right and those are
completely non-custodial offering right
so I think that what is actually proven
is that in the cryptos uh kind of in the
crypto rails you can choose between
those two models right and you know one
of them like the D5 protocols and the 49
custodial it has still some technology
risks that some people and some friction
right in terms of this in terms of
on-ramping and interaction that some
people are trying to avoid vis-a-vis the
custodial uh the custodial relationship
with uh with a
folks like coinbase or or uh
um you know the ones that I mentioned
earlier and then you're effectively
taking a very similar risk to the risk
that you were taking with in traditional
Finance so maybe the example that I'll
always like to to show uh recently is
that if you look at like you know the
the the the Inception right of actually
what triggered the the bank run on
Celsius
it is a very similar situation to what
happened with svb right because
basically the way that the background on
Celsius started was that someone figured
out that they have if locked in um SD
instead if uh deposits on um on one of
the D5 protocols one of the D5 polls and
they figure out that they have a
mismatch between their obligations to
their retail clients that they promised
them that they can withdraw that if
instantaneously uh whenever they want uh
vis-a-vis the fact that actually that it
was already locked into SDS and there
was not enough liquidity to basically
convert it that back to it to to issue
the withdrawals very similar to by the
way svb taking those deposits and
putting them in a 10-year treasury bonds
right that if you actually wanted to
withdraw that cash then you know they
didn't have they had maybe like enough
liquidity the but they had to to sell it
in a really aggressive markdown right so
it's kind of similar got it and so when
you think about what you all are
building right fire blocks is a
custodian kind of at the core and then
you guys uh have all this software built
around it and you've got a number of
different services that people can
leverage and use on the platform talk a
little bit as to how you've thought
about building this for this new
Financial system right how do you
eliminate counterparty risk or how do
you mitigate some of the risks that
people have seen on other platforms
yeah so the first thing I would say is
that Firebox is actually built uh we we
specifically call ourselves we don't
call ourselves a custodia we call
ourselves a custody technology provider
right and there is a reason for that
Nuance the the menu the reason for that
Nuance is that
we are not keeping 100 of the keys right
at no situation fire blocks is basically
has full control or full or you actually
or our clients right specifically taking
full counterparty risk to us so let's
assume that you're a hedge fund or
you're an asset manager
um for for the for uh it's like a
convenience that you when you put your
assets with let's say
um you know a fully custodial service
out there that custodial service has 100
of your of the keys they basically have
full control over your assets when you
are using fireblocks fireblogs basically
is built with a technology called MPC
multi-party computation we've been
um one of the leading research
organizations behind that technology and
honestly I think we are now probably uh
the the most uh kind of the biggest
player that is providing that technology
but the idea around NPC similar to
multisig is that at least one of the key
shares that control the wallet are with
the client right so we can't move the
funds without the client actually
initiating their key and there's one one
or many keys with the the client and
then we keep a few keeps keys on our end
to basically put safeguards or actually
run security policies to on to make sure
that the client is not being defrauded
or hacked or manipulated by either you
know the North Korean hackers or an
Insider who is in their organization
because they can pre-configure the
policies on our end so essentially you
would say you know if I'm not sending it
to those whitelisted addresses I want to
make sure that there are five people in
my organization that needs to approve it
right and then we essentially both
mitigating
collusion we are mitigating a situation
in which you know you have people that
are hacked and then the hackers are
trying to basically activate withdrawals
in their behalf so this is what we
provide kind of in a very high level
from a technology standpoint can you
talk a little bit about um kind of the
state of security around this stuff and
and uh MPC and some of the like more
nuanced components because I think
what's really important is uh I
personally when I talk to people about
this I separate out like what is almost
like the marketing message from the
actual underlying technical capabilities
and the reason why I think that's
important is uh a lot of people when
they first are like hey what is this
asset how do I hold it they need the
marketing message right they need to
understand things like not your keys not
your coin they need to understand hey
there's self-custody it's like being
your own bank but whatever all those
kind of memorable lines are but you all
are very very technically Savvy in terms
of like what's actually going on with
things like NPC can you explain that a
little bit more
yeah sure so I'll maybe I can give a bit
of the history right so initially the
concept of uh well at the very beginning
we had the private kit right so there
are only two options one of the most
familiar options is basically I will
store the private key on my computer or
I will have a ledger no matter right and
that will start the entire private key
right that had
a bunch of issues you know one issue is
that if you store it on your computer
and your computer is hacked and you have
a malware it will steal your private key
and the the hackers will run away with
all your money and if you had a ledger
Nano which is like a very secure device
the problem with it that it was offline
the problem with that was that it's
single device so how do you work in an
Institutional environment where you need
multiple people to approve all those
things were basically unsolved then in
2012 or so we came up with multisig
which was a specific protocol for for
Bitcoin that allowed us to kind of have
multiple keys that can control an
address right and that actually solved
the issue of a single point of failure
right the main challenge was multisig
was uh there were actually two two
challenges with multi-6 the first one is
that it was protocol specific so
multisig worked one way on bitcoin it
worked in a different way on on ethereum
it works like completely different way
of Salado right so it was very very
difficult to create a unified structure
unified environment that will
that you have basically like one
protocol to roll all the different
blockchain that was issue number one and
the second issue was related to the fact
that it was expensive right expensive
from fees standpoint because all this
logic is essentially deployed on chain
and you need to pay the you know you're
in order for you to operate the a single
Key address on bitcoin it would be cheap
but if you wanted to operate an address
that has 10 key holders the transaction
was actually expensive because of the
the fees MPC
solves
those two problems and the way that it
works it basically kind of
takes this problem one step uh below and
and focuses on actually the encryption
algorithm and across the entire
blockchain that we currently have you
know whether it's Bitcoin ethereum
Solana Stellar whatever it is we have
only two encryption algorithms one is
called ecdsa the other one is called
eddsa but you know for the sake of
Simplicity they are basically just two
algorithms and NPC is working on those
algorithms which means that as long as
you have only two implementations you
can cover all the different blockchains
and what it does it basically
creates this distributed key right that
every one of the participants and the
participants can be humans those can be
servers it could be mobile devices but I
can essentially create a distributed key
that never comes together it never comes
into one single location but through
this distributed keys and a distribute
computation that is built on zero
knowledge proofs you can basically
compute a transaction so as long as a
quorum of let's say three out of five of
those devices agree they can compute a
transaction but they never put it
privately together so you eliminate the
issue of a hacker coming in and stealing
all those funds from a single location
and your eliminate collusion because
there is not a single employee there is
not a single person that has access to
the entire private key without requiring
the participation of others
what types of organizations use this is
this like for family offices are there
corporations doing this and part of the
reason I asked this is uh many people
will look at security measures whether
physical security cyber security
whatever and as an individual they're
like ah I don't need that right I'm just
an individual who would really want to
take my stuff in the crypto world
they're Bare Assets and so the kind of
risk reward calculation changes a little
bit but are there very very large you
know corporations or is this for like
more investors who's kind of the user
base that you guys are seeing success
with
so honestly we see success across the
board let's start from actually even the
retail on the retail side a firebox is
not yet available there we're working on
some a solution to help there as well
but you have great companies like Zango
and you have the coinbase wallet they're
actually using this technology for
consumers it's like you know pure you
know any consumer can use this
technology right now and it will provide
them protection then when we basically
move to the institutional or Enterprise
or the business side I would say it's
actually like you know the full spectrum
of of users are currently using MPC and
not multisig they we whether it's two
guys and a dog in a in a garage that are
running uh to ladies and talking in the
garage that are basically running a
small prop hedge fund that that is
trading crypto if we're looking at a big
fintech companies and exchanges like
revolut and others if we're looking at
um
at the bigger Banks uh Bank of New York
melon
um ANZ Bank nav all those banks are also
using this solution so asset managers
big and small are using this those
Solutions so it became I would say that
the the standard
when we started in 2018 people were kind
of skeptical about it because it was a
very advanced technology that and not
many people fully understood how it was
working and the multisig was quite an
understood technology back in the days
but what happened over the last five
years is that this technology almost
propagated to everywhere and almost
every custodian and and every provider
is currently using this underlined logic
got it when you see this technology that
you've built one of the other things
that you guys are doing is you're
basically wrapping it with developer
tools so I know that you guys just
launched a whole Suite of developer
tools talk a little bit as to how you
can you know focus on the security but
then also add in kind of these developer
tools that basically are trying to
democratize access to the security
yeah so I think that's what was
happening over the last couple of years
that we started to see a shift from
people
using crypto mainly for for speculation
right or for for trading purposes and
the client base was mostly gravitating
through you know around hedge funds over
the counter that asked
proprietary trading firms and so on and
in the last you know 18 months or so
we're seeing many more developers that
are trying to build almost like real
world applications right whether those
are nft marketplaces whether those we
have actually like you know a pretty
cool company that is using us that what
they do they replace they are replacing
airline tickets with nft based tickets
right so if you
if you don't want they call Travelex so
if you if you don't want to take the
flight you can basically transfer the
nft to someone else and they can board
the flight and so you're starting to see
and I think like there are a lot of
applications in the marketing domain
that we're seeing with you know
Starbucks and Nike and so on and the
museums and other use cases so all those
in all those use cases we basically see
developers large and small right some of
those developers are already working for
established brands or established
companies and some of those developers
are just basically startups or people
that are trying to work on in a some
kind of POC or MVP and
what I think is like is is quite
critical over there is that in a very
early stage there will be
um uh developing on a secure environment
right because if there is something that
we should learn from what happened from
um I guess like all the hacks that we've
seen in crypto in 2018 2019 was that a
lot of those hacks happen to the
exchanges and the reason why those hacks
happen is that
those exchanges that are very small as
an idea they didn't really put a lot of
emphasis on how are they developing or
building things securely and then
overnight they became big but still
their underlying infrastructure for Key
Management and custody
was something that you know they built
in-house without any controls and then
it failed right and I think that now we
are slightly in a similar space but or a
similar situation but with developers
that are building applications for for
for
really real world use cases and what we
created for them and people can find the
firebox.com forward slash developers
it's basically a a set of tools and a
sandbox that the developers can open an
account they can start building their
application on testnet and there is also
like a very attractive package for them
that they can go and start working and
deploying it on mainnet and
from the beginning they can use a very
secure infrastructure for the key
management right so basically whether
they need to generate hundreds of
thousands or millions of wallets for
their users or whether they need to
deploy smart contracts and mint nfts and
and
distribute those nfts they have secure
interfaces they have policies they have
all the control stack that they need
from day one and hopefully if they are
successful in their application is
successful and you know it becomes
basically something that has a very
large user base they need they don't
need to go and re-platform right they
don't need to go and
rebuild refactor re-engineer the entire
base of their application they can start
very small and very secure without too
much uplift and then you know as it
grows the base is secure and is future
proof what do you think the evolution of
security is going to be is this going to
be something where people will be able
to use this in a very user-friendly way
like literally on their phones on their
desktop it'll just kind of be second
nature I think a lot about uh you know
when I use the internet I can have a
secure connection and there's a lot of
protection that's provided to me and
it's almost happening in the background
versus right now when I want to secure
uh whether it is Bitcoin or other assets
then uh there's a little bit of like I'm
opting in mentally right I'm making sure
that I'm doing it and so it doesn't kind
of just happen in the background do we
eventually get there
yes and I think that to a certain degree
we are almost there that was actually
the philosophy of how we developed the
Firebox in our solution and
I'll give you just like you know our My
Philosophy uh I've so yeah I spent about
like two decades in cyber security uh
so the vast majority of my career was
actually in cyber security rather than
in crypto or fintech and I definitely
agree that
most people associate cyber security and
cyber security control with the you know
McAfee or semantic antivirus that you
have on your laptop and that it
basically starts running in the worst
time possible and basically your
computer is stuck right so we sort of
View convenience and security as to
um um kind of like you know two extremes
uh on the Spectrum and they don't view
it something that can actually live
together in a very convenient way the uh
one of the only examples of a company
that was really able to do it well is
apple with a iOS and the iPhone right so
if you look at what Apple did and they
done it pretty amazing job is that when
they came up with an iPhone they
actually
came up with an amazing York user
experience but iPhone one would argue is
also one of the most secure devices on
the planet
without asking the user to ins like how
many people you know that they have an
antivirus on their iPhone right they're
basically very few there are actually no
proper uh today like you know there
aren't like in a very sophisticated
antivirus software for for iPhone right
it's not that it's
it's only it has zero vulnerabilities
but they took a lot of very interesting
steps uh both on how they build the
entire Hardware how they build the
entire software and how they build the
entire ecosystem through the app store
to find The Sweet Spot between
exceptional user experience and high
level of security I think that there is
a huge opportunity
to mimic the same approach with crypto
and blockchain and the main reason is
that the underlying
signal or the underlying
technology for for blockchain is already
built on security right basically it's
all cryptographically secure there are
if you look at Bitcoin ethereum as a
blockchain network right it was never
hacked although it is the biggest it is
the biggest Honeypot on the internet
so the solutions that are built on top
of it whether those are the custody
Solutions the wallets the way that we
interact in in peer-to-peer transactions
there is a huge opportunity to make it
very seamless and that people will need
to think about hey like did I backup the
key I did backup the key so on
and I think it's the the job of all the
people that are working on those
Solutions including ourselves
talk to me about the bear Market as
you've gone through this bear Market
over the last let's call it 18-ish
months maybe 15 months whatever it's
been now
are you seeing more of a drive to the
custody products and what we have seen
is people pulling assets off exchanges
so I'm assuming that they're going more
into kind of self-custody and
non-custodial products but are you guys
actually seeing that in in the kind of
customer flows
yeah it was someone so the the week
after FDX collapse we've seen something
like 10 billion dollar inflows right
from people pulling assets from uh from
exchanges into the
um direct custody infrastructure and
we're also working uh very hard right
now to create Solutions where at least
for institutions they don't need to they
can still basically allocate and trade
and take positions on exchanges but they
don't need to take the Full Count of
virus and refund on the exchange so
there is definitely a lot of push
towards that as well
um I I can also say that when you talk
with a lot of the consumer based wallets
uh people like Zango and Ledger and so
on they also like the the months after
FTX has been the best months that they
ever had in terms of a product adoption
and new users so yeah overall I think
that uh
there is a definitely like you know a
larger appetite and there is a full
recognition of uh
counterparty risk and you know Quality
Systems and uh and you know both
figuring out
that you don't expose yourself to
mismanagement of your assets by a third
party and also that the technology under
the hood is safe and secure and people
are asking way more in terms of what are
the certificates what were the
certifications that you have what are
the governance and controls that you
have in terms of developing the solution
you know for example we worked really
hard to achieve something it's called
ccss level three which is we are
currently the only one that are holding
that certification which is a dedicated
certification for cryptocurrency uh
wallets
so people sort of like you know looking
into into all those aspects I would also
say that people talk a lot about the
fact that it's a bear market right now
and probably it's true given the
activity volatility price point but
as a company we went through the 2018
bear market and I think it's very
different now
as we watch this all continue to play
out regulation is a big piece of it do
you think that self-hosted wallets uh
you know non-custodial wallets whatever
you want to kind of use the nomenclature
do you think those could potentially
come under even more scrutiny or
possibly in the extreme example be
banned in the United States
it's it's a amazing question
um and I think that the pendulum is sort
of like you know continuously swinging
between uh both sides of that Spectrum I
think it so uh I actually got appointed
a few weeks ago to be on the technology
advisory committee of the cftc and we
had a session over there earlier this
week and then at the
the the self-hosted wallets was one of
the topics
I think that the sensible parts or the
sensible uh regulate regulators and also
the sensible
legislators Congress people and so on
they view self-hosted wallets as a
mandatory part of the ecosystem so it's
hard to see how those can be absolutely
banned and it's hard to basically under
underwrite The Narrative of why they
should be banned there there is a
confusion on the regulatory side that
somehow assumes that if you introduce
self-hosted wallet or unhosted wallets
you undermine
specifically a anti-money laundering and
the ability to basically
Trace down
illicit activity that's actually was
proven to be not true right you can
because the blockchain is somewhat
transparent and and track and
transactions are trackable it's true
that it's harder to freeze those assets
in some cases especially when we talk
about uh kind of native assets like
Bitcoin ethereum but it's probably more
interesting if The Regulators will kind
of switch the the the the the view on
this and we'll say okay you know most of
we believe that the future activity is
actually going to be in let's go
tokenize assets broadly but you know
whether those are nfts or stable coin or
you know tokenized Securities or
whatever right and then you can actually
build a very interesting compliance
logic into the asset itself into the
smart contract and then it's actually
agnostic to whatever it was in hosted
walls and or unhosted wallets but I
think it will be very very difficult for
their regulars to bed unhosted wallets
especially given the narrative that we
have right now that counterparty risk is
important
um fully custodial Services they have
their own vulnerabilities and people
should have the option
what are you most excited about
internally
so I'm super excited about us kind of
seeing a lot of the newer use case
coming to to fruition that we've been
working on with you know partners and I
think that our investment in working
with uh payment service providers Banks
merchants and so on on the utilization
of stablecoin for transforming
transforming if the core Financial rails
and probably again the simplest property
of payments between people is starting
to pan out and I think in the next 12 or
18 months we'll see a pretty significant
explosion
on on that as being one of the killer
use cases especially as it comes to
cross-border transfers
micropayments creators economies and so
on so I'm very excited about that I'm
excited excited about the use cases
around the broadly speaking web 3 that
are sort of when you go into the
non-financial markets like you know
gaming companies brands that are using
it for for loyalty points and we're
putting a lot of Investments over there
and
and last but not least this is a bit of
a longer I think uh Horizon but some of
the works that we have around really the
core Capital markets
um it's slower in the US but especially
in Europe and more so in APAC and Africa
where you see governments really
thinking about the crypto you know
crypto rails as the rails for for for
the future of capital markets I'll give
you a quick example over there we're
working on a project with the Tel Aviv
Stock Exchange so the Israeli government
is currently working on issuing their
treasury Bonds on
um on a blockchain right so those are
kind of very I think futuristic projects
but we're starting to see those things
panning out
as we look uh kind of moving forward if
people want to find out more about the
business if they want to come
potentially work with you guys if they
want to become users where can we send
them to find more about fireblocks our
website so firebox.com and that's
probably the the place where they can
start if there was exploring what we do
and they're getting in touch with us and
then are there any types of roles that
you guys are actively trying to fill
right now or any types of people that
you're looking for
um yeah we're mostly currently focusing
on the the
say both the customer services roles and
we are also focusing on in some of the
basically r d areas where we are hiring
and then where can we find you on the
internet
um so on my LinkedIn uh Michael
and uh you can email me at the Michael
firebooks.com awesome Michael listen
thank you so much for taking the time to
do this obviously self-custody has
become a huge huge uh topic of
discussion counterparty risk both in the
Legacy Fiat system but also uh in the
crypto system Still Remains top of mind
for many people you guys have done a
great job building a a technology that
obviously a lot of people find valuable
and continue to use today so congrats on
all the success and we'll definitely do
this again in the future as you continue
to build out further
thank you so much Emily